let's go next to Steve from the San
Francisco Bay Area Steve welcome what's
on your mind today
hey David nice to talk to you again um I
was trying to think about
um how we can get more uh taxes out of
Corporations you know because
historically we're at a pretty low rate
right now
um and we don't also want to
disincentivize them and you know send
them away I don't know if that's a real
argument but anyways I was thinking
about an idea where perhaps there was
some sort of sliding scale as far as the
tax rate relative to a corporation's
profit what do you think about that
you're basically just talking about a
progressive bracketed system for
corporations
yeah basically like certain industries
of course have very high profit margins
like um like the beauty industry and
things like that
um others not so much but I'm I'm saying
like hey if you're making huge multiples
of your your Revenue you know maybe you
have a higher tax rate than a company
that's making a smaller tax or uh I
don't know that I would do it by
industry but I actually think there's
lower hanging fruit and this is
something that a lot of democratic
lawmakers have tried to go for which is
we need to have a minimum tax for
corporations and this has been part of a
number of different proposals and to be
honest I don't remember if it's part of
what Biden wants to do the the idea is
you can't deduct your way all the way
down to zero taxes the way some
corporations have done and part of what
you do is you have to eliminate certain
mechanisms uh and it's sort of beyond
the scope of this particular call but
you know before we go look into
progressive tax rates for corporations
there are very profitable corporations
that pay literally zero or have a
negative tax rate that needs to be
eliminated with something equivalent to
the alternative minimum tax for
businesses
oh yeah for sure uh you know places like
Amazon are famous for that kind of thing
absolutely yeah that's a very good
solution and I I can get behind that all
right Steve well thank you everything
good in the Bay Area
uh yeah it's uh nice and about 65 today
enjoying the California weather oh
that's a great temperature it's hard to
beat 65 in my book
yeah all right Steve thank you
okay thanks all right the San Francisco
Bay Area always great to check in good
habits have to be sustainable in order
to become habits it has to be something
you'll actually do and when it comes to
nutrition some people have hours to plan
out every meal their exact vitamin
intake I'm not doing any of that I don't
have the time here's what's sustainable
for me I start my day with just a single
scoop of ag-1 from athletic greens it
gives me the entire day's worth of the
75 high quality vitamins minerals and
probiotics I want from whole food
sources it's just simple it's just one
scoop of ag1 I get all the nutrients I
want I don't have to do any math use my
protractor my TI-83 or take a bunch of
different capsules and pills it's not
some kind of wacky supplement making a
bunch of crazy claims you know I would
not promote something like that ag1 is
just a simple product it does what it
says it does it gives you the daily
nutrients and vitamins you likely want
vitamin women a c e magnesium zinc
potassium in one simple scoop you keep
your body nourished you'll also get a
free year supply of vitamin D which I
take in the winter plus five free travel
packs at athletic greens.com Pacman the
link is down below